there is a Jonathan Chait article in New
York magazine called Trump literally did
not understand what a shutdown would do
and it points out that the shutdown
continues were now beyond two weeks and
it's increasingly clear that much like
Donald Trump's tariffs Donald Trump
number one doesn't understand what a
shutdown actually is and number two
Donald Trump has no plan for getting out
of the shutdown because now it's this
situation where Democrats just don't
want to give him the money for the wall
period because they think it's bad
policy and Trump can't appear to be the
weak guy by accepting an end to the
shutdown without money for the wall so
we get to where we are now which is a
presidential address tonight possibly to
declare a national emergency in
justifying seizing money for that wall
so we end up with Trump saying he'd be
fine with months or years of a shutdown
if that's what it takes and I've
mentioned before that most of the
government isn't actually shut down
during the shutdown but some stuff
actually is shut down and shut down with
consequence so for example the
Washington Post is now reporting that
the Trump administration didn't realize
that during a government shutdown 38
million Americans lose their food stamps
during a shutdown thousands of tenants
could be evicted without the help that
they would otherwise be able to get from
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development the Washington Post explains
that the Trump administration is only
now realizing that this happens and now
they're trying to figure out without
ending the shutdown how can we help some
of these people who are been being hit
really hard by the effects of the
shutdown that we've decided to do
knowing Trump he likely was thinking
back to that short few days of shutdown
in early 2018 and he thought not much
really happened so not much will happen
if this lasts weeks or months or
whatever except after a few days things
do actually start to go haywire people
going hungry not having food stamps
means they'll stop spending money if
their food stamp money at grocery stores
which is bad for the grocery stores
you've got the TSA working without pay
and starting to stage days where they
all call out sick
this could spill over an impact air
travel which would [ __ ] industries
tax refunds will be in jeopardy
once the filing window opens in February
and people can start filing their taxes
and expecting refunds what will happen
when people can't get their tax refunds
because government is shut down and just
like with the tariffs there was no
thinking before the shutdown about how
it would work there's also no thinking
about what the off-ramp is and I think
it's important to mention as well Mitch
McConnell has to be blamed it's not just
Trump unlike Trump Mitch McConnell does
know how government shutdowns work and
he's refusing to put up bills to a vote
to reopen government so this might not
accomplish anything either way Trump
might not care if McConnell wants to
reopen government but if we actually had
Republicans other than like the lone
couple of voices that are out there
saying we should reopen government if
Republicans and Democrats were pushing
for a reopening of government without
necessarily having to fund the wall it
maybe would serve as some pressure on
Donald Trump would a red state airport
shutting down be what it takes to get
government reopened Pat maybe but what's
increasingly clear is that he doesn't
even understand the consequences of his
actions and the only lens through which
he makes these decisions is the
political lens and the lens of will I
seem like the winner or the loser in the
end yeah
government shutdown is very serious
especially once against into weeks and
months into that time range and House
Democrats have tried to pass several
bills that would reopen parts of the
government like agriculture and the
Treasury and Justice Department the
stuff that has nothing to do with the
wall eke you can save that conversation
for later keep the debate going on
whether or not we should have a wall and
whether or not we should fund the
Department of Homeland Security until
that debates over with but Republicans
are having on a bit of course
Republicans having none of it and of
course the House Democrats within hours
of taking control of the house passing a
bill that would have reopened government
but McConnell's not hearing it Trump's
not hearing it so anyway Trump didn't
know what would happen during a shutdown
he probably still doesn't even really
get it and all that matters is will he
come away feeling that he won or will he
come away feeling that he lost nothing
else will matter not the people going
hungry not the fact that this could
crippled air travel none of it makes a
difference to him it is truly idiocracy
2019 send me your thoughts how long will
this go on what will it take to end the
shutdown I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and we have just a tremendous program
for you today today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]